bonjour bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france concrètement qu'est
ce qui va changer pour vous à partir de
demain
bonjour à lorsqu'il vachon ce qui va
changer à partir de demain c'est
qu'effectivement l'état d'autres plus de
masques
mais l'état nous a vivement encouragé
ces derniers temps a stockés des masques
en prévision d'une éventuelle seconde
vague seconde vague d'ailleurs quand que
l'on commence à percevoir ici dans les
pyrénées orientales
mais oui mais alors comment est ce que
vous vous êtes organisés ces derniers
jours est ce que vous avez pu facilement
constituer un stock de max notamment
comment combien ce que ça vous a coûté
non en fait l'état à de donner à chaque
infirmière libérale 24 masques par
semaine et c'est cette dotation in
s'arrêter s'est arrêtée d'ailleurs lié à
samedi et donc moi j'ai réussi à
constituer puisque je n'utilisais pas 24
masque parce qu'à l'heure actuelle
j'avais pas de patients ayant un horaire
étant atteints du code vide
donc je n'ai pas utilisé ces stocks
donc je les ai précieusement gardé ce
qu'il faut souligner c'est que nous
avons enfin des masques non périmés ce
qui n'était pas le cas au début de nos
dotations nous avons travaillé avec du
matériel périmé dangereux dangereux pour
nous dangereux pour les gens on soigne
donc à ce niveau là l'état n'a quand
même pas rempli sa fonction
voilà de protéger de protéger les gens
et le personnel soignant mais
aujourd'hui vous estimez que vous êtes
équipé notamment en masse pour affronter
les prochaines semaines et peut-être une
détérioration de la situation sanitaire
non non non non je suis pas suffisamment
équipés dans la l'état les jeunes et a
fait passer cet
cette entre guillemets cette restriction
est ce retrait pendant les vacances de
juillet faut savoir s'adapter quand même
de 5 juillet cette initiative de l'état
de nous demander attribué cette dotation
déjà ils nous ont même pas consulté et à
l'heure actuelle quand j'entends ce que
vaut le commentaire que vous avez fait
le reportage qui nous dit qu'on est
probablement dans une seconde vague donc
je n'ai pas non non j'ai pas du tout
assez de masques pour faire face à une
vague mais qu'est-ce qui vous pèse
aujourd'hui la difficulté à trouver des
masques on sait le prix que cela coûte à
l'heure actuelle je dirais plutôt que
c'est le prix maintenant trop des
masques alors je ne sais pas exactement
la qualité de ces masques 1 puisque la
différence entre les premiers masques
que nous avons eues et qui était périmé
et ceux de maintenant
maintenant il n'y a plus de date il n'y
a aucune date de péremption sur ces
masques il faut le savoir aux cigales
donc il dit qui dit pas date
voilà je sais pas si matériel que m'a
fourni l'état a et de qualité voilà il
ne me met pas en danger et surtout ne
met pas aussi en danger les gens que
j'essaye de soigner et préservé voilà
alors la direction générale de la santé
tente de rassurer en cadres bon
épidémique l'approvisionnement des
professionnels de santé libéraux ou
d'intervenant à domicile elle sera
toujours assurée par les pharmacies
d'officine qui recevront du stock de la
part de l'état selon le modèle éprouvé
ces derniers mois fin de citation est ce
que cela vous rassure
si c'est effectivement le cas et si
c'est ce qui va réellement se passer oui
évident enfin oui voila je vais pas je
vais pas non plus enfin le plein mais si
c'est pas le cas et si ça met autant de
temps que ce qui s'est passé au début de
l'épidémie où je crois que le
gouvernement n'a pas été à la hauteur et
n'a pas n'a pas voilà n'a pas compris
les enjeux de ce qu'est une pandémie
et effectivement oui il ya de quoi
s'inquiéter
mais si si effectivement l'état pu
reconstituer des stocks et que
maintenant en fait l'approvisionnement
honnêtement la sur le dernier mois il
n'y a pas eu de souci je vais pas non
plus complètement dénigrer ce
gouvernement puisqu'il est quel parent
responsable entièrement de ce qui s'est
passé
surtout je parle pour le début de
l'épidémie donc voilà oui si ça reste
comme celle à l'heure actuelle le niveau
d'approvisionnement non je vais pas me
plaindre par rapport à se cacher l'état
non merci d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions et nenad
dufrègne la fléchette je rappelle que
vous êtes infirmière libérale membre du
collectif sos soignants en danger